welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Robert Shiller the Arthur M oaken
professor of economics as well as a
professor of Finance at Yale School of
Management the new york times
best-selling economist is probably the
only person to have predicted both the
stock market bubble of 2000 and the real
estate bubble that led up to the
subprime mortgage meltdown yet he has no
apologist for the sins of finance today
we talk with Professor Shiller about his
new and very timely book finance and the
good society where he argues that rather
than condemning finance we need to
reclaim it for the common good
welcome professor Shiller pleasure to be
here let's begin with why you wrote this
book well I've been teaching finance for
25 years at Yale and I am launching
young people on their careers
now Yale has an open Yale version of my
lectures that are broadcast all over the
world so I'm developing people to be
either directly in finance or to be
somehow involved in in finance I think
ours I thought of myself as preparing
people to live in our modern society
which is I call financial capitalism but
the the crisis the financial crisis that
we've had since 2007 has a lot of people
doubting the value of finance and
there's a lot of angry criticism Occupy
Wall Street sure and so I feel that sort
of a quandary that I'm preparing the
students for what I'm sure is a good
thing on the whole but people don't
appreciate that and I wanted to write a
book which not only shows the value of
finance but shows the way our society is
going to evolve as a
nancial capitalistic society okay
in your book you write financial
capitalism is an invention and the
process of inventing it is hardly over I
don't think most people think of it in
terms of that and do you think that's
part of the problem
definitely it's part of the problem we
appreciate when Apple computer invents
some new system we are kind of awed by
that and we think that they deserve the
money they earn right but when when we
do something like securitized mortgages
in finance it looks a little bit like
somebody's scheme to get rich and the
benefits to society from securitizing
mortgages are harder to see it's not
like you get some new fancy electronic
gizmo that flashes and does amazing
things it's just that you can get a
mortgage at a lower rate and you
actually get the mortgage to buy a house
and so it's not as visible but actually
designing something like a securitized
mortgage takes a lot of work and
creative inventiveness in terms of the
reputation of Wall Street today being so
porin and so many people have lost money
yet some people still continue to make
millions upon millions of dollars let's
look at some of the ways finance
historically has contributed to society
well I would say that we are living in a
period where the examples of the
advantages of finance are all around us
all over the world we are seeing the
phenomenal growth of China of India and
in fact of just about any major segment
of any emerging economy and what's
happening is that the financialization
of the economies of the world and what
it's doing is it's bringing people into
modernity it's bringing them good
healthcare clean homes all sorts of
wonderful things
and I really think those things would
not have been possible if we stayed in a
traditional old-fashioned the economy
okay what do you think the role of
Finance should be for the good of
society well I think it it should be
more disbursed it should be broader than
it is now
more democratic for a Democrat that's
the term I used in the book that there
has been a process over centuries
towards the democratization of Finance
by that I mean if you go back to the
18th century not many people own stocks
there weren't very many corporations but
that has read out and developed into
much more now that is true but for
instance take the situation we have on
our hands now where many people invested
in the stock market and then lost
significant portions of their portfolio
how can we prevent or somehow negate
that from happening down the road well
the world or can we write the world is
fundamentally uncertain we don't know
the future and financial market
fluctuations reflect that but the the
uncertainty of the world can be managed
substantially we have a theory of risk
management there's a mathematical theory
of it now and the there is also a
behavioral theory that explains people's
psychological problems in managing risk
but even if we don't know the future
there are things we can do to lessen the
impact of them like what well like
diversify invest and diversify
when you say diversify what do you mean
that means the old adage is don't put
all your eggs in one basket that makes
it sound obvious but in that as a matter
of fact most people don't even today
so we we have to get the word that we
need better investor education we need
better advisors we need advisors that
are available for the more general
public and I think that we're moving in
the right direction you know it's part
of the progress of civilization so I
think that as the years go by in coming
decades we will see financial
institutions even more an integral part
of our lives and they will look
different the next 10 20 30 years will
be different how do you do you have any
insights as to what differences there
may be well it has to do with electronic
technology and we are all very used now
to search engines and algorithms of one
sort or another I think that we will
have retail products that will help
people manage their risks right now not
many people avail themselves of
financial technology they they go
through life owning a house that might
lose value and suddenly they're wiped
out oh they might specialize in a career
and then the career turns out not to
have been a wise choice
like you could become a nuclear engineer
and we have we have bad events and then
suddenly you're not you're in trouble
these are all risk that people face and
as we democratize finance I think what I
think we will see more and more help in
managing these risk well that's good
because I think people do need help I
think for some people it can be
overwhelming to try and understand what
is going on in the financial market and
how best you can navigate it to you know
reap the benefits for yourself and a lot
of people put their trust and financial
advisers and that perhaps may not always
be that the best way to go and and in
terms of that I mean you know you talk
about the sleaze factor in your book how
can we move away from that well the
financial industry is off
opportunities to make money in sleazy
manipulative way right a little bit like
politics you know they don't make maybe
money but they they have a sleaze factor
problem as well so I think that we need
how do we deal with it you know in my
book I describe it as a mall issue right
for my students or other any people who
are in the industry and it it poses
difficult problems one problem is that
there's always going to be sleazy people
around you and how do you deal with that
you get dragged down by them and your
own reputation is harmed by these other
people but I don't want ones theme is
that I don't I think we have to be
self-assured those of us who are doing
business or somehow related to finance
self assured that I am a good person I
have a moral standard and this is what
we teach in business schools of a kind
of moral standard that underpins I have
a sense of optimism in the book that
most people are not sleazy and you have
to be careful not to be over over
reacting to some elements of sleazy you
know that everyone messes up there's
always some people I think you know the
Occupy Wall Street people are very
focused on some sleazy examples but it's
not it's not that bad a situation and I
think it will gradually get better and
regulation helps with that and and we're
improving our regulatory apparatus
especially with the crash of the market
and and I think I don't many things have
been put in place to a guard against
that happening down the road some
conclusions in your book how can we
reclaim finance and harness its power
for the good of society give us some
examples well I can give you historical
examples of important invention the
stock market is an invention it's a very
smart invention in terms of what it
provides for
risk-management what it provides for
human psychology getting people involved
getting them incentivized to do
coordinated work to allocate I could go
on and on it sound like it but it's
something that has to be improved it's
still not done and there are and when
you say it's it's not done yet it needs
to be improved what can you cite one or
two things that can be done to improve
it well one example that is only about
two years old it's not my idea but I
talked about it in the book is and it's
a little subtle a little bit hard to
capsulize there's a new kind of
corporation called the benefit
corporation okay which has now created
in eight US states it's a u.s. thing I
think it will be exported to other
countries eventually but right now it's
very small it's just starting a benefit
corporation is different from a standard
corporation in that its corporate
charter says that it's not exclusively
in the business of making profits it has
two objectives a profits for the
shareholders be some other objective
that is stated in the at the time of the
founding of the company in its Charter
and so you've got dual objectives and
these other objectives are may be in
conflict with the profit-making
motive but I I suspect that this new
corporate form will be important and
that even people who are interested in
investing for the profits the company
makes will choose to invest in that kind
of company and in fact that kind of
company may turn out it's an experiment
now it may turn out to be better at
making profits than a conventional
corporation because it's more humane it
could be if the if some of the other
purposes are human purposes about the
community or society or the environment
and I think that this is an important
innovation which we
are just starting now here and in the
21st century well that's exciting I
hadn't heard about that is it in terms
of an entity is it legally different
from a regular corporation okay the law
in the United States has imposed a duty
of loyalty to the board of directors of
a company loyalty to the shareholders
that is cardinal in US law and in other
countries as well and so a director who
does something for the community would
be violating the duty of loyalty and
could be subject to a lawsuit for doing
that so it's definitely a different
legal structure that we now have and I
think more and more states are going to
adopt it and foreign countries will
adopt it are these being traded now
currently and whilst they are but I
don't have a big final question
professor if there was one thing that we
can take from your book what would you
want it to be well having written a long
book there are many things I know I know
but I think I think that we should be
thinking of financial capitalism as a
kind of Organization for society that
respects human differences respects the
different contributions that different
people can make and it doesn't put
people in a straightjacket it doesn't
put them in a you know you belong to
some institution now take orders from
your boss that may happen too but what
I'm saying is there's an element of
self-reliance and an element of
everyone's on the lookout for how to
make a better society we have in it will
be integrated with our modern electronic
new capabilities in search
but I think that people with this the
world is never going to be perfect but I
think that people will be able to find
their purposes they'll find fulfillment
of their deepest purposes better it's
not about making money money is only to
be spent for some purpose and I think
what I want my students and anyone who
reads this book is to come into business
or finance with a high-minded
purpose we don't tell you what the
purpose is but we you know we hope that
anyone who does go into business or
finance will have some higher purposes
that ultimately all of this driving is
is aimed at very good finance and the
good Society fascinating stuff thank you
so much for being here today and sharing
it with us my pleasure for more
information about Professor Robert
Shiller please visit our website at Yale
ddu backslash Macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through the funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Centre for International
and area studies at Yale